yeah think about ceos you know people
always complain about ceo pay they don't
understand how it works
um think about this uh if you're running
a public hundred billion dollar company
right like your ceo of a real company
it's worth 100 billion dollars
i'm sure you can find competent people
who do that job for half a million bucks
a year for a million bucks a year 2
million bucks a year but imagine someone
comes along who demonstrably has
slightly better judgment
like you know 85 percent instead of 75
percent of time there right well you
will pay that person
you know 50 million 100 million 200
million dollars whatever it takes
because that 10 better judgment is
steering a 100 billion dollar ship so
ceos are highly paid because of their
leverage so small differences in
judgment and capability really get
amplified look at professional sports
nobody wants to watch you know the third
place the bronze medal winner everybody
wants to watch the gold medal winner so
the gold medal winner will get paid
multiples because their leverage their
reach is to millions of individuals
whereas the bronze medal winner has a
reach to hundreds or thousands of uh uh
of individuals um so they can just so
just for being a marginally better like
running that quarter mile and you know
fraction of a second faster they're
going to get paid a lot more orders of
magnitude more
so leverage just has that effect and
magnifies things so being at the extreme
in your art uh
is very important in an age of leverage
and you're never going to be the best in
the world at anything unless it's
something that you just absolutely love
to do
no one can compete with you on being you
no one can compete with me on being me
so when i think about what my profession
what my job
what my work is it's just being me what
am i doing on periscope right now why am
i here i'm just me being me i don't have
any other good explanation for it but i
just know no one's going to beat me
being me so if i ever need to make money
off of it i can and i'm going to be darn
good at it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you